- SOFTY. THE BIG SOFTY.
- MM-HMM.
- HEY, THERE.
WHAT'S THE MATTER?
SWIM PRACTICE CANCELED?
- UH, YEAH.
- THAT'S COOL. AT LEAST
YOU GET TO SLEEP IN, RIGHT?
- ACTUALLY, THEY, UM...
THEY KICKED ME OFF THE TEAM
AND TOOK MY SCHOLARSHIP,
SO...
I'M KINDA SCREWED SINCE
MY DAD'S MAKING ME
PAY MY WAY THROUGH SCHOOL.
WHATEVER.
EX-JOCK COMING THROUGH.
HEADS UP.
[knock on door]
- HEY, WE JUST WANTED
TO CHECK ON YOU
BECAUSE YOU WERE CRYING
PRETTY HARD IN THE SHOWER.
- FROSH DOGS, GET IN HERE
AND HELP ME
POLISH OFF THIS CASE,
SEEING AS THAT I'M NOT EVEN
YOUR R.A. ANYMORE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- YEAH, COME ON IN.
- THESE WERE ACTUALLY
OUR BEERS FROM BEFORE, SO--
- OH, THESE ARE YOURS?
- YEAH, THESE ARE OURS.
- SORRY.
- SO YOU GUYS WANNA
MAKE A TOAST OR SOMETHING?
TO...UH...
LET'S GET DRUNK!
- YEAH!
- NOW WE'RE TALKIN'.
- ALL RIGHT!
ONE, TWO, THREE, CHUG RACE.
all: CHUG RACE!
- YOU CHUG IT, BOY.
CHUG IT!
- THIS IS A WRESTLING
FIGURE-FOUR, BABY!
- OH...
OH, OH, OH, OH, OH, OH.
♪ YOU WORK AT A SMILE
AND YOU GO FOR A RIDE ♪
♪ YOU HAD A BAD DAY,
THE CAMERA DON'T LIE ♪
♪ YOU'RE COMING BACK DOWN ♪
♪ AND YOU REALLY DON'T MIND ♪
- [belches]
- ♪ YOU HAD A BAD DAY ♪
[laughter]
♪ YOU HAD A BAD DAY ♪
- YEAH, I JUST--
YOU KNOW, I GOTTA GO.
I GOTTA GET GOING, SO...
UM...THANKS...
AND GOOD-BYE FOREVER.
- YEAH, BYE FOREVER.
- BYE FOREVER.
- YEP.
- [sighs]
PBBBBBBB...
- SO THAT GUY'S GONNA
KILL HIMSELF, RIGHT?
- YEAH. MM-HMM.
- ALL RIGHT.
WE'RE THROWING YOU A PARTY.
- WHAT?
- YEAH, WE'RE THROWING YOU
A MASSIVE PARTY
THAT EVERYBODY'S
GONNA COME TO.
AND WE'RE GONNA MAKE
ENOUGH MONEY
TO KEEP YOU IN SCHOOL
FOR NOW.
- LIKE VAN WILDER?
- YEAH, LIKE A LOT OF MOVIES.
- I'M TECK.
- ALL WE NEED IS BEER...
AND DRUGS...
- AND TITTIES.
YOU GOTS TA HAVE SOME TITTIES,
BABY.